so you and most are married and then
what happened you have a baby now yeah I
had a baby and what's that like it's fun
is it you're pregnant he showed me the
photo of when he first knew the baby and
that was the first time in my life that
I actually felt my ovary kick no offense
but I mean just saying like I never felt
any type of like you know I never really
wanted to have a child but when I saw
that photo I was like oh my god what
about the photo made you want to have it
didn't you feel the same way I did yeah
what do you do when I put that when they
put the baby on me yes yes that photo
oh my god that was so scary because like
everyone's like you have to have
skin-to-skin I didn't know what that was
then this soon is because I had a
c-section so it's like scheduled so like
it was scheduled for 10:00 a.m. and at
10:07 they're like get they took the
baby out of me and then put it on my
neck and I was like but it wasn't washed
or anything but did you have that
bonding moment no I was just like get
that it give it a bath like it was just
like it was a little too like dirty yeah
no I mean I just thought it's your baby
I know but I was I was on drugs and they
had just like for her from me all right
right here washing rinse it rinse it
well it wasn't even that it was dirty it
was just like I didn't know what I was
supposed to feel yeah I yeah and how
long was that baby on you yeah it looked
back at motion he just looks scared
oh no and he had scrubs on and he
everyone's like we didn't know what we
were supposed to feel is everyone's like
it's gonna be crazy you know but it's
like it's just a stranger that's like
right put on your neck you know yeah but
there's not that instant love and
connection that I was dreaming it's not
how Bobby Cobb
I'm like oh this is life-changing in the
picture I remember smiling during you
don't know so maybe it's maybe it was
like beyond what I really saw the photo
and I'm like first of all and don't take
this the wrong way but you're the
probably the last person I thought would
ever have a baby because um and I also
don't want you to take this the wrong
way but your um your fancy right but
lots of queens have had babies that's
true princess yeah but I always like
looked at Natasha as like almost royal
you know thank you because she is
slightly regretting it got her little
shots today and she started crying it
was a very upset Oh need to get him if
to give him the vaccines oh how do you
feel about the anti-vaccine today if
something happened to her I would become
an anti vaccine McCarthy there were
people who are really rallying against
this I have no feelings about that Moshe
is very Pro vaccine so I just listen to
him I know instincts so like I kind of
looked good yeah yeah like people asked
me how about raising the kids stuff like
I don't even know you were supposed to
spank your kids do you guys know that I
didn't know that you're not supposed to
like you are absolutely nothing but you
can't spank your kid no America you
can't just put him over your knee and
slap on my bike it's been proven that it
doesn't work but is it illegal no it's
not illegal
oh I'm good then really work for Asians
it worked we were all spanked yeah it
was look at you I had to pluck my brace
might when I had braces I had to pluck
the wires out Oh for my lips I Gila
mouthing mom didn't tell me she boxed my
mouth no I resented her for a long time
so no I don't plan on boxing my kids but
it'll spanking maybe you're really I
mean I'm just telling you when you guys
have a baby and you're in a play group
and you tell someone that you spank your
kid they it's it's really bad really is
to beat me with a golf club and I'm not
like like the putter and as hard as it
can against my legs a piano I swear to
God he would say for ya with that and
then the piano
Steve as Steve him and I had like a
lightsaber duo because when I got older
I'm like oh you're gonna use golf clubs
[ __ ] I grabbed it a golf club but how's
your relationship now he's dying but he
was great you know I am you know I see
him I love him and I have no resentment
at all towards the man do you do you
remember being spanked yes my mom had
this thing called the paddle and it was
like a silver thing of wood because she
was a single mother so she was always
trying to find ways to discipline us
yeah and then I remember she it hurt
yeah but did you just use it all the
time on you or no all the time like it
didn't feel abusive but it definitely
felt like a threat what's the cutoff age
of like acceptable for spanking I'm
telling you it's like so taboo right now
okay but I know noted don't think
there's a cut-off because it's like
every it's just kind of improving in the
same way that I don't know what well
know how there's just ways that you have
to act now yeah you have to comply I
know it's but I don't want to spank my
child anyway yeah don't I mean you know
what we don't spank our dog's our
parents used to talk [ __ ] about each
other to us you know what I mean like
people kind of know not to do that now
like things have been like proven and
change changing changed a little bit the
whole world is sensitive is what you're
saying yeah well I'm not even saying
that I'm saying like there are also
certain things that we've learned
through evolution like yeah it's bad to
pit your kid against you know like how
the parents pit like your dad's an
[ __ ]
[Music]